wasserstoff aus ernte abfällen gewinnen
eine kopf transplantation und die
ursache für das massensterben im
zeitalter bern
das sind drei der themen jetzt in den
krieg zum top news
erneuerbare energie große mengen
wasserstoff aus mais bio wasserstoff aus
ernte abfällen klingt komisch ist aber
mittlerweile eine gute quelle für
erneuerbare energie die art und weise
der energiegewinnung soll laut forschern
effizienter sein als bisherige methoden
forscher um personal von der virginia
polytechnic institute and state
university in blacksburg erreichten die
dreifache dreifache ausbeute von
bisherigen verfahren eigenen angaben
zufolge gelang es ihnen aus den
häufigsten kohlenhydraten der pflanzen
den maximalen ertrag an wasserstoff
herauszuholen insgesamt kommt ihr
verfahren das elf unterschiedliche
enzyme als biologische katalysatoren
verwendet
auf eine ähnliche produktivität wie die
industrielle herstellung der große
vorteil von wasserstoff bei der
verbrennung entsteht lediglich wasser
kein kohlenstoffdioxid das den
klimawandel fördert zudem kann das gas
in autos als treibstoff eingesetzt
werden in ihren versuchen verwendeten
die wissenschaftler stängel und blätter
von maispflanzen die daraus gewonnene
zellulose wurde aufgespalten
mit einer phosphat gruppe verknüpft und
über enzyme reaktionen wird dann
wasserstoff freigesetzt durch ein
virtuelles experiment basieren auf den
praktischen versuchen ließen sich die
bedingungen für die wasserstoff
gewinnung schließlich noch optimieren
noch dauert der prozess mit rund 78
stunden recht lang ist aber mit
hitzestabil ihren hitze stabileren
enzymen und höheren temperaturen noch zu
beschleunigen
säure in ozean verursachte größte
massensterben von 252 millionen jahren
fand das größte massensterben der
erdgeschichte stadt ausgelöst wurden die
zwei vernichtenden schläge gegen die
lebewesen auf der erde durch starken
vulkanismus in
sibirien dabei soll viel
kohlenstoffdioxid in die luft gefeuert
worden sein dass die ozeane nicht
aufnehmen konnten
daraus folgte eine übersäuerung der
meere was zum aussterben vieler arten
zum ende der periode perlen führte zu
grunde liegt dabei die reaktion zwischen
dem wasser h2o und kohlenstoffdioxid co2
daraus entsteht kohlensäure hardt 2 c o
3 aufgrund dieser reaktion spielen die
weltmeere eine wichtige rolle im
gleichgewicht der atmosphäre da sie ihr
co2 entziehen und damit auch den
treibhauseffekt beeinflussen können
zum großen aussterben im kern führte
eine gigantische menge an co2 die durch
vulkanische aktivitäten in einem kurzen
zeitraum in die luft gelangte
um diesen überschuss zu kompensieren
dank der ph-wert der ozeane rapide ab
woraufhin viele tierarten starten
allerdings bleiben noch einige fragen
offen beispielsweise was die erste welle
des aussterbens verursacht hat die
forscher der studie sehen in diesem
szenario eine gefahr für die zukunft der
vom menschen produzierten co2 ausstoß
hat bereits dazu geführt dass der
durchschnittliche ph wert um 01
einheiten gesunken ist
noch scheint das nicht tragisch zu sein
dennoch warnen die wissenschaftler vor
den konsequenzen eine kurze meldung zur
versorgungsmission der nasa am kommenden
montag also in zwei tagen vom online
stellen des videos aus wird die
mittlerweile sechste mission von spacex
2 ss gestartet und halb vier
amerikanischer zeit wird der countdown
von der nasa im netz gestartet und
dokumentiert etwa eine stunde später
soll sich die rakete space sechs völkern
ein dragon also das raumschiff heißt der
dragon in die lüfte begeben
an bord sind neue experimente ausrüstung
und verpflegung um die beobachtung der
erde und die weitere erkundung des
weltalls voranzutreiben für alle
interessierten gibt es in der video
beschreibung einen link mit weiteren
informationen
wie man hiv besiegen kann
unzählige antikörper sind der nächste
schritt im kampf gegen hiv in einer
studie konnte mit hilfe spezieller
antikörper die konzentration von virus
molekülen um das 300 fache gesenkt
werden die antikörper sollen vor einer
infektion schützen aber auch bei
infizierten zu einer heilung beitragen
drei bnc 117 so der name des antikörpers
bindet das gefährliche hi virus und
macht ihn so unschädlich das hört sich
leichter an als es ist denn das virus
mutiert stetig und verändert seine
oberfläche sodass das körpereigene
immunsystem probleme damit hat darauf zu
reagieren und entsprechende antikörper
zu bilden solche antikörper müssen also
von außen zugeführt werden durch eine
infusion der neuen antikörper mit einer
konzentration von 30 milligramm pro
kilogramm körpergewicht konnten die
wissenschaftler die messbare menge der
viren im blut deutlich senken dadurch
wiederum wird das immunsystem entlastet
und so der körper gestärkt das problem
bleibt aber dass die antikörper nicht
langfristig wirken wie die studie
gezeigt hat für die wissenschaftler der
studie sind ihre ergebnisse weiterer
schritt zum sieg über die krankheit um
hiv aber vollständig heilen zu können
müsse weiter geforscht werden so die
wissenschaftler
kopf transplantation freiwillige vor
valerie spiridonov 30 jahre alt aus
russland möchte der erste mensch sein
dessen kopf auf einen anderen körper
transportiert wird der italienische
chirurg sergio cannavaro hat zu beginn
dieses jahres seine idee erläutert wie
eine vollständige transplantation eines
kopfes durchgeführt werden könnte ja
bislang hört sich das er nach einem
science fiction film an
durch den 30 jährigen russen gibt es
jetzt aber
den ersten freiwilligen und damit wird
die idee weiter geführt also jetzt wird
nur noch ein körper benötigt von einem
freiwilligen dabei wird das vorhaben für
den kopf viele risiken
die vermutlich 36 stündige operation
müsste von rund 150 ärzten und helfern
durchgeführt werden
wie viele fehler dort potenziell
passieren könnten
das lässt sich relativ leicht ausrechnen
zudem kann es sein trotz erfolgreicher
transportation wenn alles klappt würde
es könnte dazu kommen dass der kopf des
russen von dem neuen körper abgestoßen
wird immunreaktion die folge er stirbt
das problem das gewagte vorhabens ist
dass der kopf auch mit dem kompletten
restlichen nervensystem mit jeder faser
verknüpft werden muss nicht nur
einzelnen nerven wie bei anderen
transplantationen an diesem punkt da
sind sich die experten einig dass es
momentan noch viel zu kompliziert
bereits in den 1970 er jahren hat man
eine kopf transplantation durchgeführt
allerdings an einem affen er überlebte
insgesamt nur acht tage da der körper
eben den neuen kopf ab stieß und er war
unfähig zu atmen und sich zu bewegen
alles in allem vermuten die experten aus
der medizin dass eine derartige
operation zum jetzigen zeitpunkt nicht
erfolgreich möglich ist denn noch bis
2017 möchte der italienische chirurg
cannavaro eine kopf transplantation
durchgeführt haben
huhu anderes thema in dem hörbuch limit
fördern amerikaner und chinesen ein
element auf dem mond welches die
energieversorgung der erde sichern kann
helium-3 ein super spannender science
fiction thriller und den könnt ihr
kostenlos bekommen wenn ihr euch über
unseren link einen probe account bei
audible erstellt link ist und in der
video beschreibung genau so wie alle
quellen für die heutigen themen und was
meint ihr werden wir wirklich in naher
zukunft eine solch unglaubliche
operation miterleben wird sie klappen
ich finde die vorstellung davon eher
etwas gruselig also sommer das wirklich
massen machen diskutiert es wie immer
mit mir in den kommentaren und wie wir
unseren körper außerdem modifizieren
können erkläre ich euch in dem video
sind wir alle cyborgs
das findet ihr hier und hier unten gehen
wie immer zum blog und ansonsten bis
dann wie immer stand schreibt franz